i don't know just be a good person what
about that just be nice to people you
know
yeah like uh a lot of it doesn't add up
i can't keep track of all the rules
like transgender what do you think
that's how i feel i don't give a [ __ ]
you want to go for a man a woman go nuts
well go labia
what's the beef look it's weird to hate
someone because they're trans right but
it's also weird to love someone because
they're trans shouldn't you like them
based on who they are as a person
content to the character people are so
phony i love caitlyn jenner why
she sucks
she's against gay marriage and ran over
a person what's the good part
then they go well they have hard lives
all right well so do bidgets
why don't you talk about how much you
like them where's that hashtag i don't
see any tweets about midgets
who's got a heart at a minute how are
you around hard to drive hard to get
work no love and look i'm not anti-trans
but i am pro-midge
i just don't get why we help one group
but not another it's just kind of trendy
and people say well trans aren't allowed
everywhere well you're in a roller
coaster
[Music]
at least trans we accommodate with the
bathrooms [ __ ] ever see how tall a
toilet is
well imagine having a jump to take a
dump
weird no help no support
you know what's great about midgets i
got a couple [ __ ] friends they're good
eggs
you never see a [ __ ] complaining never
every other group complains never [ __ ]
never see it on the news sitting at a
desk legs dangling little fish shaking
never every other group complains i see
women on news we have a glass ceiling
midget's like you're worried about the
ceiling
holy [ __ ] i'm trying to [ __ ] with this
counter baby
interesting see i guess i'm too
open-minded because i support all
transition not just sexual why do we
stop at sexual i support transition to
personality transition of uh
opinion right like kevin hart kevin hart
got in trouble with some offensive
tweets from years ago
i'm not the same guy i was from years
ago i've transitioned i used to have sex
with 16 year olds
when i was 16. now i don't i'm different
well years ago he said some offensive
stuff well years ago she won the men's
relay people change
why do you support that and not that huh
it just tells me if i ever get in
trouble now i'm just gonna get a sex
change because you gotta kiss my ass
hey mark we heard the interview from 10
years ago that was mark
i'm margaret
i don't know i support kevin hart also
because he's a [ __ ]
[Applause]
oh there we go i never went to college i
said that earlier but i never went
i didn't go because i had to pay for it
and uh i always figured that at 18 years
old if i had enough money to pay for
college
i was probably doing all right already
i also don't feel like we need college
for everything you know like if you're
going to be a doctor
lawyer probably a good idea if you go to
college you know what i mean but i
didn't want to be those things
and i didn't know what i wanted to do
but i figured we don't need it for
everything you know building roads
building houses we'll figure it out you
know what i mean
abraham lincoln built a house he go to
college i don't know
[Applause]
not even sure he built a house i'll be
honest with you
that's just what people tell me i don't
know and they named the logs after him
so
that's got to mean something
[Music]
yeah i didn't like school i didn't like
handwriting you know what i mean you
print for a while and then they try to
make you write
in cursive i always hated that like by
the time i'm perfecting print they want
to slip in cursive on me you know
like it's like it's the evolution of
print you know that's not what it is
cursive's like prince weird cousin that
likes touching way too much
okay we're having a good time and um
i never like reading that's why i don't
like to read though when i was a kid
little kid there was this tv show called
reading rainbow you guys remember that
show
i had a host on there i had a host a guy
named levar burton
trying to get everybody to read books
all the time then he showed up on star
trek blind
that's what reading does
that's why i don't get into it i am uh
currently engaged right now i say
currently because after this
is on tv that might be the end of it all
recently had an argument um i found out
that some couples get married on a
friday i asked her about it
she said oh it's cheaper i know a lot of
people do get married on saturday but
she said yeah it's cheaper it's cheaper
to do it on a friday
she got upset with me when i suggested
that we do it on a monday morning
it seems to me like you get paid to do
it on monday morning
your friends are like hey when's your
wedding it's like it's actually on
monday morning right before you go to
work so
just wear whatever you're gonna wear to
work there's obviously no reception
you have people drunk at work
i don't even know about uh non-alcoholic
receptions you actually don't ever know
about you have to actually find out the
hard way
that those exist you get to the
reception hi i'd like a beer actually
when we have sweet tea and water
what what was that your brain can't even
process
the information what
you know weird that is to instantly
going from someone who wishes the
newlyweds well
to someone who hopes they get a divorce
immediately
i hope you have diarrhea the entire
honeymoon
[Laughter]
i do live with my fiancee um which is
great if anyone's thinking about getting
married or you
you're you're thinking about proposing
live together first i highly recommend
that
um i know some people are against it a
lot of religious people like well if you
live together before you're married
you're gonna go to hell and that's
exactly what marriage can become
when you don't know each other that well
so it's kind of when do you want your
hell do you want it now
later take it later take it later
i keep thinking about the uh the
bachelor party i don't know what we'll
do
um i don't know if you guys know this
but in amsterdam they have legalized
prostitution
i'm not saying that's what we're going
to do that's just a
just a bad segue that's all that is
i haven't slept with a prostitute i
probably have the same reservations
every man in this room has when it comes
to sleeping with a prostitute you know
what if i fall in love
i was at a friend's house recently and
they had a uh
they like a ouija board sitting out
right and like i'm
familiar with ouija boards like i i know
like the concept behind them but i never
seen one like
up close i had no idea that they're made
by like
milton bradley you know like who that
company in the board meeting was like
you know what kids need i think
dude is there a game where you could
talk to [ __ ] ghosts yet is that okay
because i think kids would like that i
think
could you call it i don't know or
something with pedophiles i don't know i
think that's fine
i was [ __ ] around with that idea in
my head but like then i was thinking
more about it and it's really it's not a
way for us to talk to dead people
because that's not what ouija boards are
right because like
you don't really get to pick the ghost
you play like 20 questions you have to
figure out who the ghost is you're like
oh did you die
you know it's [ __ ] someone's moving
it but the whole idea is you ask
questions
uh so it's way for dead people to talk
to us which means that there's ghosts
lined up waiting for a chance to use a
ouija board right
and can you imagine how shitty it would
be if you were dead
and your only form of communication with
your loved ones in the outside world
was through the hands of a fat teenage
girl thinks she's a vampire
some just chubby cutter john edwards
sprinkling donut powder around the
entrance to her bedroom trying to
channel a boyfriend
my name is david smith i live in 512
maple crest do you like my chemical
romance what are you talking about
do you i not understand how important
this is you need to tell my wife
does dennis have a crush on me who's
dennis
how would i know that i'm a ghost not a
psychic and you know the answer is no
please
i just go to hell this is so much worse
than hell i'd rather
be another one you ever got to put your
foot up on something to look cool and
then you realize that it's a much higher
surface than you originally realized i
was at a party the other day talking to
a girl i'm like yeah i do comedy it's
pretty sweet
oh that looked a lot lower when i
started this move
you can't panic you got to go with it
i'm like yeah i just thought i want to
see my balls through my jeans here
your knees should never be higher than
your genitals in a conversation
that's a good rule of thumb just
generally
i was in a hotel recently we have
anxiety everyone has a solution i was at
a hotel the hotel room had a steam room
i mean that hotel had a steamer not my
hotel room i'm not doing that well
ah the hotel had a steamer my buddy's
like you gonna go take a steam a steam
room is really relaxing
a steam room is relaxing if you're the
only person in the steam room
that's relaxing then you hear that door
swing open and you realize that somebody
else has entered the steam room
but you can't see them because it's too
steamy that's no longer a relaxing
situation
now you're in some sort of weird ghost
porn
i'm just sharing a tiny steamy space
with an elderly naked man that i can't
see
until he's a penis distance away from my
face
i'm like hello is somebody in here and
you can't feel around for him that's no
good
i'm just laying in a puddle of ringworm
all of a sudden a spirit dick appears in
front of my eyes
i'm like ah you guys are great thank you
very much